[Applaudissements]
une égalisation dans les ultimes
secondes de la partie les rouges de
trappes y ont cru jusqu'au bout ce
dimanche 22 avril contre l'équipe des
gobelins en match en retard du
championnat de régionale 4 pourtant tout
avait mal débuté pour les trappistes
dominé en début de partie ils concèdent
l'ouverture du score mettra pas fait
preuve de caractère en égalisant face au
leader du championnat
score final un but partout on se dit
quand on a toute façon plus rien à
perdre
la preuve sur un dernier coup de pied
arrêté notre gardien est monté on se
contentait pas de doute la défaite on on
voulait absolument arracher le point du
match nul et voire même la victoire mais
pas à s'étendre
malheureusement on était venu
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas eu de ya pas
une banque les joueurs ont tout donné
alors que la chaleur ça peut couper que
c'est pour nous larmes de mon côté je
vends pas de rue repas parce qu'ils ont
fait ce qu'il fallait avant tout donner
un but à la 90e minute qui pourraient
avoir une importance cruciale pour la
suite du championnat trap est
actuellement 12e sur 14 équipes engagées
dont il nous reste maintenant cinq
matches on a encore trois à domicile
contre elle les points le plus
rapidement possible pour assurer le
maintien qui était pas l'objectif de
début de saison mais vu les événements
du fer avec ea voilà le sien c'est un
bon match nul pour nous mais en fait
nous on en fait un match en retard
donc ça permet de gagner au camp rock et
quoi en fait à trois points donc là nous
faut encore deux victoires pour assurer
le maintien pour la première de ses cinq
finales à disputer d'ici la fin de la
saison les trappistes se déplaceront ce
dimanche 29 avril sur le terrain de val
de france une équipe classée dernière de
ce championnat